body we managed to interrupt the drug
Supply in Northampton for a full two
hours so seven months of work nine
months 96 people arrested
being constantly in fear of my life
being assaulted you know I was at one
point I was stripped naked by that guy
enjoying operation
and all of those things that I went
through
for the sake of interrupting the drug
supply for two hours
[Music]
thank you
Neil we've met before obviously but for
any new listeners or watches could you
just briefly describe Who You Are
yeah I'm a former undercover police
officer from the United Kingdom so I
used to catch drug dealers for a living
and now I'm part of the international
movement the law enforcement Action
Partnership better known in the UK as
leap UK and what does that aim to do
we are part of where we are the growing
movement of police and other law
enforcement who are calling for an end
to the War on Drugs uh we call for an
evidence-based drug policy
um interesting and we'll get into that
in a little more detail but I guess
what I'd love to do is go back to kind
of the beginning of your career
uh you were an undercover drugs officer
what was the actual title is that
correct or have I said it completely
wrong
I I don't know um just undercover police
officer really undercover police officer
uh what age did you start the undercover
section of your job
um I was 23 yeah it was 1993. 23. so how
does someone get into undercover police
work
um well I mean I just fell into it to be
honest uh you see I I started in the
police now I was when I started in the
police I was really terrible at it I was
a very young 19 year old
um uh put this uniform on and I I really
I mean I didn't realize how young and
naive I was until I was in the police
put it that way I didn't deal with
confrontation very well
um I just felt like I was quite
sheltered so I struggled to stay in the
job to be honest and I only stayed in
for the first two years just to prove to
myself I could and I was hating every
minute of it right
but I settled in a bit more and I stayed
in then it became four years I was in
the job
um but then I got an attachment to The
Drug Squad
um just I
think the month's attachment to start
with um so when you say you had an
attachment to The Drug Squad is that
just a standard thing that happens in
the police that people get put in
different places no it happened then
because of a particular shift in
politics in 1993 so in the UK at that
time there was the mother of all moral
panics about drugs and that was about
crack cocaine because the Tabloid
newspapers had been telling the British
public for years that there was going to
be this problem and they kept publishing
stories about how crack cocaine was
destroying America right with an
emphasis on on black neighborhoods a
very sort of racist coverage of of what
was happening so the moment that crack
cocaine did finally hit the streets of
the UK there was a panic big moral Panic
that had been whipped up for years
so there was lots of pressure
from the public
and this this was perceived as a
political pressure from the government
which they they then demanded of the
police do something about this
so
the government actually set priorities
for policing and they said that you must
make the investigation of heroin and
crack cocaine your number one priority
above anything above domestic violence
above anything at all
and so there was enormous amount of
financial investments in drugs policing
and so part of that was the idea of
giving young rookies like me an
attachment to The Drug Squad and try and
share this expertise Now The Drug Squad
hated it because they they were very
specialist unit you know trained in
surveillance and there were seasoned
detectives and to have people like me
under the under their feet got on their
nerves a lot but
when I was there one of them looked at
me looked me up and down and said um you
fancy having to go up buying some crack
cocaine
which was so quite surprising request
you know but I thought you know I'll I'm
game for anything
and so I was given 20 quid and pointed
to this particular door there was a
rapidly set up observations point with a
camera and
and um yeah I went to knock on this door
and this this huge guy onto the door and
said
who are you what do you want you're not
a [ __ ] student are you I [ __ ] hate
students and there I was looking at him
thinking I've got no idea who I am
because I hadn't thought about that
about a cover story or anything I was
just told to knock on the door
so I thought well that'll do yeah I'm a
student
and this woman behind him said is he
[ __ ] stupid you just told him you
hate students
but he laughed and um and he offered me
a a wrap of crack cocaine from several
in his hand and I took it and gave him
20 quid
and I walked back to The Drug Squad and
I went there you go I've got it
and that defined the next
14 years of my life
because that kind of undercover work
hadn't really happened in the UK before
right now don't get me wrong I didn't
invent undercover work it'd been going
on for a lot longer but normal
traditional undercover work was was very
high end you know it was introduced by
informants at the top level
not worth buying
um single wraps of Street dealers you
know with no cover story
or training or anything yeah so how
rapidly did it get from you doing
oh I'm a student here's 20 quid to
literally designing a whole cover story
and who you were for six months at a
time
two years wow um but in that two years
in that leading up to that I was doing
sort of several weeks at a time yeah
um or I would be doing more than one job
at a time one one would be returning to
a particular Pub in in leicestershire
um
arranging to buy stolen cars of this
particular cocaine dealer but in the
week I'd be doing another operation
somewhere else so
so yeah it was like it was quite busy
and in between that I was still going
back and doing like a couple of shifts
in uniform
because it was quite confusing and then
I was told right from the outset that I
was not to tell any of my colleagues
what I was doing because that would be
dangerous
which because why would it be dangerous
well this is something I didn't
really truly understand at the start but
I was told in no uncertain terms I must
not tell anybody the work I was doing
now obviously this was seasoned
Drug Squad officers people who've been
detectives investigating drugs in drugs
crime for a long time and they knew what
they were talking about and they made it
clear to me
and they basically said you can't trust
anybody invest when you're investigating
drugs organized crime they have moles
everywhere and I I mean I did as I was
told you know I didn't tell anybody and
that made it quite um
a strangely lonely place to be honest
but it was many years later before I
realized the genuine risks
of it and how much
how different it is
doing normal policing to doing drugs
policing
because corruption isn't a problem in
normal policing it's only a problem when
you're investigating drugs no that's
interesting that's interesting and I'd
love we'll get into that in a bit more
depth I think but so just going back a
little bit then so you're still a fairly
young man and when you say about going
to a pub uh over and over again for a
couple of weeks to buy cars off a a drug
dealer or something stolen cars at that
point when you're doing that
um
did you feel like you had a shield
because you knew you were undercover
police officer and you knew that if it
was uncovered who you were they might be
afraid to do something to you because
you were a police officer or did you
feel in danger at that point
no I very much felt in danger uh very
much so I mean for example the pub job
where I was buying various things
um
I'd seen the intelligence about these
people and I knew how dangerous they
were and I mean and they were genuinely
dangerous people
but it was the danger which made me
I suppose there's a danger that made me
develop now I was I was a I was
genuinely a pretty crap cop uniform cop
um certainly the first two or three
years
but I'd found within the cover work I
found something that I could rapidly
develop in and it suited my personality
and it suited
um the way that I could develop and
and that danger the risk you know made
me made me develop very quickly very
quickly and also I learned by mistakes
and I made some dangerous really
dangerous mistakes and you know when you
when you come close to physical injury
it's amazing how you quickly develop
yeah of course yeah I suppose the
penalty for failure was quite high in
your in your specific role yeah exactly
I mean one of the big mistakes I made
particularly with that Pub job was um
to have something to talk about I made
myself out to be a connoisseur of
amphetamines all right okay which I'm
I'm clearly not at all
but you know I would talk about the old
days of Dexys and the different tablets
and the different types and how much
nicer methamphetamine is to to your
normal British and fetamine sulfate and
these things like this
and uh you know just because I'd read it
in a book I thought I could pull it off
and I suppose I was doing until one day
this main target of the operation
came to me and said hey you
I've got something for you
and again we held up this little Sealy
bag see-through bag with this sort of
pink toxic looking goo in it oh God
and he said you're gonna love this
and I'm thinking yeah okay and the
trouble is he must have picked up on the
momentary reticence on my face just a
flash of reticence
and I then picked up on the fact that
he'd picked up on my reticence because I
could see a momentary down to cross his
face and I knew in that Split Second I
had to pour water on that suspicion I
had to otherwise this was only going in
One Direction I was in trouble I know
from that Split Second I was in trouble
so I had to show him enthusiasm
so I said yeah yeah great
but that's yeah dip my finger in and put
it in my mouth and he looked at me and
said you're going to need more than that
with your tolerance oh God I think you
know I'll get it okay so I stuck my
finger in again and got a big blob and
put it in my mouth and could almost feel
the mouth also you know foaming on my
tongue my tongue dissolving and went
down my throat it was hot and started
that weird warm feeling in my belly
and of course within about 20 minutes I
was completely out of it I was it was
at the time the average seized
amphetamine was five percent pure
40 pure right genuine base
um
and now I knew enough about the drug
that I wasn't going to overdose but I
was it was a rough ride I mean it was
too intense it was anxiety-inducing it
was horrible so did you have to get away
from here oh I had to get out I had to
make my excuses right now yeah I had to
make thanks for the amphetamine now I've
got to immediately leave yeah I just
said yeah I'm gonna go party I'm not
gonna party you know I'm gonna go to
this place and I'm gonna go to this club
I'm gonna meet up with this person and
um but actually what I did is scuttled
back to my backup team and went to the
safe location and uh quickly dictated
some notes and then got driven home and
I couldn't drive yeah that leads on to
an interesting point actually
um which I see a lot of people asking
about on the internet because I think a
lot of uh this is including myself a lot
of our understanding of how undercover
work works is from Hollywood films yeah
so there's this kind of like you know it
always splits between the films that
show that you're not allowed to take
drugs and that's how the criminals catch
people out and the films that show that
you can take drugs to maintain your
cover so can you clear that up for us
well yeah I mean clearly you can it's
just it's just common sense you know if
I needed to take some drugs to maintain
my cover then then I needed to to do it
it's as simple as that really and
thankfully it very rarely happened very
rarely
um because you develop a good sense of
survival and I wish I'd developed
survival for that day because I tell you
what I didn't sleep for three nights oh
God but mind you my house has never been
so tired right okay you know when I was
being driven home I was daydreaming
about the fact that I've got eight cans
of lager in the fridge thinking that's
going to to take the edge off all right
to finish the eighth can I felt no
different at all Jesus I mean thankfully
I didn't I mean I had to have cannabis a
few times but that's just cannabis in it
you know but uh thankfully I never had
anything I had to have anything stronger
like heroin or I mean crack cocaine
wouldn't have worried me particularly
but heroin would have done
um you know with no tolerance I suppose
it would be a strange situation where
someone would force you to take Heron I
guess wouldn't it unless you'd build
your cover to be around someone they
took it well someone was really
suspicious once it was it was I was in a
car
and the the guy that was introduced me
to the dealer was in the front seat I
was driving
the dealer got in the back and I knew
they were suspicious of me that
certainly the dealer and the dealers May
so I knew how to cook up so what I did
is I parked up in the street and I
cooked up in the car so I got my spoon
and my lighter and threw the filter in
put some citric acid in
cooked it up till it bubbled put it into
the barrel
and uh drop my trousers
and went position my groin to inject
into my groin
and inject it into the car seat
wow so you know that was that was one
way that at that time it you know it
built it they never doubted me after
that so I guess the groin thing is good
because presumably they wouldn't be
actively staring into your groin so it's
a way of kind of yeah exactly and
they're not gonna they're not gonna stir
and and it is the most I have to make
this very clear for for from harm
reduction advice going into the groin is
the worst thing you can do right people
do go into the groin because it doesn't
heal properly I think you can keep going
into it all the time
and so quite often people go into the
groin because they've damaged veins in
their legs and arms and going into the
groin it doesn't heal up the same so you
can use it for longer but it is
incredibly dangerous you know and uh and
then would you so when you did that you
kind of injected into the car seat would
then you would you then have to act in a
way that would you know make it look
like you just received a
an injection of heroin I could have done
and there have been times when I would
play uh gouging or rattling gouching
being and being under the effect of
heroin or rattling being
um
making out that I'm withdrawing but on
that occasion I didn't behave any
difference at all it's just I was
presenting myself as a problematic
heroin consumer who was who was just
stopping myself being ill really okay
so let's move to the bit that you talked
about earlier about the uh the longer
periods of time that you'd spend the
extended periods where you'd spend in a
role so can you talk us through how it
worked like when you arrived in a new
town like would they say you're going to
this area to investigate this area or
would they say we want you to
investigate this gang or this person who
lives in this area can you just talk us
through how it works with moving
somewhere and setting yourself up so
quite often before I went to a place I
would we would have the opportunity to
build up a legend so for example if I
said that I'd spent the last six months
um
at selling on a market stall in the town
of Chesterfield and I used to go to a
pub in Chesterfield and knew that you
know I would have to spend time going to
that Pub in Chesterfield right it was
checked up then I would know the name of
the person behind the bar and I would
know
um enough detail about that to survive
any intrusive sort of
um
surveillance from the opposition so to
speak so you you put those kind of
things in place and you think very
carefully about the legend and with
every passing year that Legend had to be
thought about in more detail much more
detail
but whenever I went to a place now and
this is an important Point actually so
I'm glad you've asked me this this
question
because wherever
say that a constabulary wanted to run
this operation they would have to run it
as per the rules of the East Midlands
Special Operations unit according to
National guidelines but once this team
was assembled and it tends to be
assembled from those people who involved
in crime investigation who are good at
what they do they would all be told that
they must not
communicate at all
before or during the operation with any
other cop and they would be set up in a
building completely away from the police
station they would be cocooned from it
completely separate
and just before I got there they would
all be sat down and given a written
lawful order
and they would be told you must not ask
the undercover operative their real name
or where they're from or any other
personal details and if you do you'll be
disciplined
now aloof loader is a big deal in the
place
it it it really makes you sit up and
take notice that you know you're going
to be in trouble if you breach this this
lawful order now the reason for that
lawful order is to protect me
but to protect me from who it's to
protect me from my colleagues and the
fact that this safe location is separate
from a police station and it's cocooned
from normal operations is to protect me
now this is important to note because
that kind of protection
doesn't exist for any other kind of
policing
this is only for drugs covert
investigations
because let's face it that's trying to
protect me from corruption and the
corruption doesn't exist in any other
kind of policing and do you think that
process exists as a uh really stringent
safeguard for things that could possibly
happen or do you think its existence is
an acceptance that the corruption is
real
very very clearly it is because of an
acceptance that the corruption is real
it's an attempt to defend against what
is accepted to be endemic
so
right yeah I mean that's
that must have been quite a an intense
thing for you in the sense that I guess
what you've described there to me it
feels like what you're saying is you go
into that situation once you get in
there what you're essentially being told
is all these people who are now
responsible for keeping you alive
potentially might be corrupt yeah and
might actually not have your best
interests at her yeah exactly that and
I'm using the same pseudonym
and fake details to the gangsters on the
street as I am to the cops that are my
backup
yeah that's really what you're doing and
quite often I've had times when I wonder
who I might feel most at risk from
really more often than I would that I
would
like to dwell on too much to be honest
really and did you ever feel that
throughout your time there there was
places you were when you felt I'm not
quite as safe as I'd like to be with
this group of uh colleagues yeah
absolutely operation in Leicester in
2001
um
some very strange things happened at the
end of that operation where I did not
trust the activities of my team and I
still went out on the streets and that's
when I ended up having a gangster find
the hidden camera on me when I was
already suspicious of my of my backup
team from their behavior
and and that almost got me killed
because he found that camera and I ended
up being chased across the car park by a
car a car trying to drive down a
pavement after me and trying to run me
down
and they missed me by two meters you
know and I'd gone seven months of that
operation without any problem like that
and you look back on that time now and
and you know how do you feel about it do
you think it was coincidence or are you
still suspicious about
um absolutely suspicious especially with
things that happened to me with the
years afterwards I mean
I suppose my most infamous or my my
biggest brush with with corruption was
within the operation in uh
Nottinghamshire
now for the Nottinghamshire
investigation there was lots of pressure
under me for
to find out about
the sort of gang wars that were going on
at the time because at the time the best
wood cartel he was run by Colin Gunn
was at war with everybody else and at
the time the shootings
in Nottingham were major news like front
page type you know newspaper news there
was talk that because of this daily
shootings in Nottingham that the home
office was considering
um
taking control of Nottingham Chicago off
the chief Constable right you know it
was that bigger news
so there was that kind of pressure going
on
now
I was only on the periphery of the
Basswood cartel's operation I wasn't
high-end but I was doing my best to get
close to them and I did buy drugs off
one of his lieutenants
but after four and a half months into
that operation I just
I'd just been interrogated by that
particular Lieutenant he he interrogated
me with and he went with a knife pressed
into my groin
which is really uncomfortable I cannot
tell you in fact it's quite off-putting
um was that just a routine thing or did
he become suspicious of you I think that
was his routine because testing yeah
just testing
um you know taking me four and a half
months to get to an introduction to him
sure
and yeah he he was
vicious so that had been a long day at
the office so to speak the next the next
day the next morning
two of my backup team went off sick you
know we'd been all working long hours
and so I was introduced to two new cops
so the first one
I met him no problem at all shook his
hand
the next one shook his hand and the
hairs went up in the back of my neck and
I was just deeply suspicious of this guy
you know but when you've been working
undercover for for months you know
you're
sensors are pretty fine-tuned you know
you're very sensitive to even for
nuanced body language and this guy was
just wrong
so I complained to the sio the guy in
charge and I said look boss I can't have
this guy knowing what I'm doing so he
excluded them both he was great so I put
that on my mind I was reassured so would
he say anything like why would you just
say it's a gut feeling I don't like it
and that was enough that's what I said
to him and that was enough for him right
he said well if you're not happy that's
it great which yeah there's good support
from him really
so he we he just got rid of them and
they hadn't been in the briefing so
there was nothing lost anyway I put that
on my mind having been reassured 12
months later when collingham was brought
down by a very
uh huge detailed operation by
Nottinghamshire Conservatory it turned
out that that cop had taken an exception
to a guy called Charlie Fletcher was an
employee of Colin gone my God so it's
clear that Colin Gunn got closer to my
inner circle than I did to his by some
considerable way now Charlie Fletcher
was paid two thousand pounds a month
on top of his police wages plus bonuses
for good information
and by the time I'd met him he'd been in
the police for seven years right
and it's only good fortune that he was
caught now in the debrief for that and I
met with some senior police and one of
them at the time said to me look Bootsy
of course we know this happens with this
much money involved how can it not
happen
now people should let that really sink
in because this is an attitude I've
heard from many senior police not just
in Britain around the world
that it is accepted
that organized crime is so wealthy from
the organized crime that control the
drug Supply are so wealthy that they can
routinely corrupt police that they pay
people to join the police they pay
people to join the prison service and
other institutions
and that our drug policy has caused
blanket corruption
that's accepted now I think it's
important for the public to know that
because if the public understand that
then they will bring bring pressure on
the political systems that make things
change okay so just just to jump back a
little bit so when you arrive in a new
place and you are integrating yourself
with the community and you've got a sort
of um I guess a mission that you're
trying to accomplish what was your
feelings about the people that you were
meeting like with the drug users or the
drug dealers were you seeing them as
sort of enemies of the state were you
seeing them as people that were bad and
needed to be put in prison or were you
just was it just a job for you you know
like what was your connection with them
yeah I mean when I started working
undercovering for the first few years I
was really pleased to be doing the work
not just because it was making me
develop I was feeling myself getting
better at it and and because I you know
I I found it enjoyable as an
intellectual exercise as well but also
because I felt like I was doing the
right thing you know these drug dealers
were destroying our society as I saw it
and I I looked down completely on the
people who were using these drugs
problematically I I saw them as less
than human because I was I saw them as
people who were stupid enough to have
tried these drugs in the first place and
didn't have the willpower to get
themselves out of it I just looked down
on them you know really judgmental
but I suppose it was my method at
developing the tactics that really got
me to see them clearly because I
realized if I needed to survive in order
to keep myself safe in that environment
I needed to understand how to behave and
in to do that I needed to understand who
I was who were my peers my apparent
peers in that environment which is the
most problematic heroin and cocaine
users sure people who are living on the
edge of society living in squats or
they're homeless or or part of that
community
and in order to get to know them and
understand them better I spent a lot of
time listening to them and it became
clear to me that every single one of
those people had a story every single
person
and or all of them
were where they were because of
childhood trauma
all of them they all had an abusive
father like one guy said to me yeah I
used to get battered but it's all right
I know I deserved it
yeah and that was such a common phrase
or
Uma one of the kindest people I've ever
met this young woman called Uma and or
that was a nickname in in Northampton
she said to me yeah I can give up heroin
and I do regularly to bring my tolerance
down I'll stop for two weeks but the
trouble is the end of that two weeks
I've become suicidal
because I remember the feeling of my
uncle's fingernails as he sexually
abused me as a little girl geez
so she was using heroin to blot out that
emotional pain and for her that was a
completely rational decision because
heroin was keeping her alive and that's
not uncommon I met lots of people like
that and time and time again I was
listening to these people and thinking
well if I'd been through that I would
more than likely be in exactly the same
place yeah so that's just something I
hadn't understood as a as an arrogant
young man really yeah it's
so complex isn't it and I can see how as
a young man as well who was at the
height of his game and doing a good job
and probably being rewarded for it that
must have made it even more hard because
you're going I'm doing really well here
and yet this I'm getting these creeping
feelings of morality but before you got
to the point where those feelings of
morality sort of um took over could you
talk us through some of your most
dangerous operations
well I told you the one about
um when the guy found my camera and he
and he tried to kill me with the car did
you always have a camera on you would
that always be a thing well you wouldn't
wear a camera to start with because you
you very much at risk of being searched
to start with so I I would take the
decision to wear one once I perceived
the risk of being searched to be
sufficiently reduced got you so the
thought of being in a situation like
you're describing knowing I had a camera
or what you know in the movies they're
always the most tense scenes where
someone's wearing it and the people are
talking about searching them and stuff
like that the adrenaline must have just
been unbelievable in those cases well
yeah and this is how I suppose
um the death of a Thousand Cuts for PTSD
works because I've got complex PTSD I'm
diagnosed and it's a chronic condition
for the kind of things I've experienced
it's not just one singular event it's
not it's it things that eats away at you
it's the death of a Thousand Cuts so in
2001 you know I had a cap my camera was
found and it almost got me killed
so when I was wearing a camera in 2004
yeah when I put it on I I was my heart
rate went up I was sweating I was having
to calm myself and I was having to
rationalize it and for that operation
for the Burger Bar boys when I when I
uh for anyone for anyone who's unaware
who were the Burger Bar boys Okay so
back in 2004 I think that's the year I
did that operation the burger boys were
a very Infamous Gang
um
Infamous for being regularly at war with
their Rivals the Johnson crew in
Birmingham uh the main target for my
operation was implicated in seven
different murders he was also the person
who provided the machine guns for the
murder the infamous murder of Leticia
Shakespeare and Charmaine Harris
so they were they were very notorious
and they were genuinely very brutal
um they'd taken over the drug Supply in
Northampton so the Birmingham gang where
they were spreading their implements
so when I studied the intelligence like
I have to do as a as an operative to
agree that it was a Justified operation
they it was quite clear in their parade
in the intelligence that this gang they
were using sexual violence as part of
their reputation building you know they
were gang raping people for drug debts
and male and female that's part of the
intelligence yeah wow
um
and in fact during the operation they
did a gang rape in one of the in one of
the cars that I was that I knew them in
and that morning the car was found burnt
out so they were very good at covering
their
their tracks they were very Savvy they
were very brutal and I had to really
develop a good Legend and I spent a long
time trading in stolen property go going
shoplifting with with some
Street people which was great fun
um which actually that's another
question so are you allowed to commit
crimes to maintain your cover yeah yeah
um if it's Justified I mean look at it
this way I never had any intention of
keeping the stolen property I would take
it back to the safe location so that
means that the active theft isn't
complete because I've I have no
intention of permanently depriving it
um but but again it would it could be
easily Justified even if you know if
there was a theft
um so yeah I did cut shoplifting and it
was good fun uh I know I had I had to
get out a free jail card which means I
didn't have the same concerns of a cheat
code yeah so um
so I spent a long time
developing a reputation and finally
getting an introduction directly to the
Burger Bar boys they would only deal
with certain people directly I've been
buying off their minions
and that day when I got an introduction
I was taken to where they were sort of
holding Court the sort of temporary
headquarters which was a snooker Club in
the center of Northampton
I was directed in there and I was
directed into the gents toilets which is
quite a big room
several cubicles and urinals there
and within a few moments the door burst
open like banged open dramatically and
this hooded figure came in and he went
into the cubicle
stood on the toilet and looked over the
closed door
and said what's this
and I got an introduction from the from
the guy who was who my mate who I got to
know
and then he
the next thing the door burst open again
and four more hooded figures came in and
they came in and they started walking
around me in a circle
and the guy in the cubicle was asking me
questions and asking my mate questions
and change sort of
changing the nature of the question
trying to catch me out and as he was
doing this
they were
one of them would headbutt me on the
side of the ear
although another one would push me
another one would punch me in the ribs
and all of the time the sort of violence
was starting to increase and my ear was
hurting you know if you'd been
head-butted on me and it's surprisingly
painful
but this sort of sense of imminent
extreme violence was building and I knew
what they were capable of you know I'd
seen the intelligence I'd heard what
people have been saying on the streets
and I really thought that this was it I
wasn't I was either going to get
murdered or I wasn't I was going to be
left in a beaten bloody mass in there
and all the time I'm answering these
questions so you just try not to react
to the violence are you just answering
questions and then being here you're not
saying yeah why are you hitting me or
anything you're just no no I didn't say
anything to them I was just answering
his questions and putting up with all of
it and that was the right thing to do
that was the right Behavior for who I
was purporting myself to be in
my poor mate he was shaked he was
literally shaking he was just pale
dripping with sweat and shaking and and
the thing is he'd made me learn an extra
cover story that we'd known each other
for years right he was backing me up by
saying yeah I've known him for years
mate but she hasn't yeah he was just
trying to get me the hookup that I'd
asked him to do
so it was
and I'm also another another worry I had
was would my mate would my new mate
suddenly bottle it and say no no I don't
really know him I didn't know that
so um
yeah anything any manner of things could
have gone wrong and then all of a sudden
he said
all right then
what do you want
and I went I'll have one and one please
as polite as that I said what I'll have
one and one please meaning a 0.4 deal of
heroin and a 0.4 deal of crack cocaine
and I gave him 40 quid
uh and I was given yeah he handed me he
handed me the drugs because as soon as
he said all right what do you want then
without saying the word the fourth they
just
went out in single file like all
coordinated beautifully choreographed
and and they did the deal
and then we exchanged phone numbers and
he put me as my nickname
and
weirdly okay I should explain this
really but my nickname for that
operation was Woody and so anyway we're
exchange phone numbers and I knew I was
in there and that was the most important
part of the operation I'd got past that
barrier from that point onwards I spent
months Gathering evidence of conspiracy
against the whole gang the six the six
burger bar boys and eventually 90 of
their
wider gang you know the backup team
people who were working for him Runners
sex workers all sorts of different
people
but I should make a point about the name
why I called myself Woody
and the reason is because I've got to a
point where
I was so disturbed by the corruption
that I'd come across you know I told you
about the the undercover that the cop
was against
um and there's so much corruption I'd
come up against that I'd gone into that
operation genuinely nervous or genuinely
feeling completely vulnerable to
corruption completely
and so my way of dealing with that and
still doing the job was to sort of stick
two fingers up with the universe right
to just say [ __ ] it
I'm gonna use almost my real name and
that was a huge operation that bringing
down that gang right that was one of
your biggest ones that was easily the
biggest easily yeah in terms of in terms
of I mean I think I'd had um 56 or 60
people arrested for the one previous but
this was 90 96 people and Not only was
it 96 people it was literally every
single person involved in the trade in
that town like everybody
so seven months into it I'm thinking wow
this this is going to be huge because
there isn't any that I hadn't there
wasn't anyone I'd met I I'd met everyone
involved yeah I've got everyone's number
there was no new phone numbers to me
there was no names I'd heard I hadn't
met and bought drugs from and when did
it start to shift for you when you
started to realize that you didn't
believe you were having a positive
impact anymore
yeah and that's a difficult question to
answer to be honest because I went
through a long process of
being resistant
to
the conclusions that were forming in my
head you know I kept being faced with my
own
realization you know the evidence was
quite clear in front of me but I kept
being resistant to it so I kept going
through these internal ethical
discussions with myself
look these people need help I'm praying
on them look this is not having any
impact but
really the
whereas I was resistant to the obvious
conclusions the real Hammer blow which
made me Force up face up to those was
the end of that operation because
I was so excited you know 96 people all
these people are going to be arrested
there were hundreds of cops involved in
that hundreds
and every single person in that trade
was caught everyone
so the Intel officer for that operation
was tasked with keeping his ear to the
ground to find out the impact of that
operation on the streets of Northampton
and he spoke to me week a week or so
afterwards after the dust had settled
and everyone was arrested he says yep
Woody we managed to interrupt the drug
Supply in Northampton for a full two
hours
so seven months of work nine months 96
people arrested
being constantly in fear of my life
being assaulted you know I was at one
point I was stripped naked by that gang
during that operation
and all of those things that I went
through
for the sake of interrupting the drug
supply for two hours now I don't know
for sure that the Burger Bar boys
Infamous Rivals the Johnson crew were
the people who took over the drug Supply
but you can sort of picture the scene
can't you the rival gang gets a phone
call they start laughing amongst
themselves hey boys
put the order in buy loads more gear
because guess what the cops have done
for us the cops have locked up six of
the Burger Bar boys let's go and take
over Northampton and is that is that
just because there is always it once a
void is created there's just a load of
people waiting to fill that void in
terms of suppliers always at every
single level at every level both
city-wide regionally or internationally
wherever we're at your the world
it's the same story
the police
never reduce the size of the market
they never reduce the size of the market
but we do something because we do all
this work what we do is we change the
shape of that market
and that changing shape is never an
improvement and what I mean by that is
that you create a sudden Gap in the
market
yeah you created a massive money making
opportunity massive because we're
talking vast amounts of money here
it's fought over by more than one person
so more often than not
Police Operations police successors and
I used the word very Loosely those
successes lead to an increase in
violence
but more importantly from from one of
the themes that we've talked about today
is the corruption the impact on
corruption
now covert police have said to me look
of course corruption happens with this
much money involved how can it not but
it's more complicated than that
policing activity actually leads to the
corruption
because when you
and I've done this but I've arrested a
gang or Kingpin character that controls
the supply of a quarter of a city the
gang that's most able to take up that
opportunity is a gang that controls
another quarter of the city so what
you're doing is you're increasing the
influence of the privacy and actually
often organized crime use police
informants to get the police to get rid
of their rivals
so they're using the police as that
mechanism so the police are either doing
it directly for organized crime or
unwittingly for organized crime and what
happens over time is not necessarily at
street level but further up the ladder
it means that over time monopolies are
created
or cooperatives are created and this
happens at every level only last year
the National Crime agency or various law
enforcement agencies slipped out an
announcement that
British organized crime groups and
organized crime groups are now allied
with Italian mafia
now there used to be Rivals they didn't
used to work together but now they do
they formed a Cooperative they share
their resources
now when you get monopolies and
cooperatives
it means that they have more disposable
income
and if they have more disposable income
they have more to invest in corruption
and all and the biggest asset of
organized crime is corruption
so the mechanism of policing
is increasing the corruption over time I
mean you're painting in an exceptionally
Bleak picture of the effects of policing
drugs but for people listening I suppose
one of the things they'll be asking is
well what's the alternative you can't
presumably just go okay no more rules
and no more police can you
well no I mean this this is this is the
misunderstanding about the way things
are things are not controlled now they
are out of control because prohibition
is an absence of rules it's an absence
of control
the alternative is to take control away
from organized crime by legally
regulating these drugs
drug prohibition has not worked it's
been and is being a disaster
drugs have never been more available
they've never been cheaper or stronger
or more varied
organized crime has never made as much
money as they are making more money with
every passing year so the alternative is
to take control
it's starting to happen the the many
countries now have legal cannabis
markets North America Germany is about
to go legal malta's just gone legal
and cannabis takes a lot of money away
from organized crime but we need to go
much further and we need to do it
urgently
another example of Regulation that's
been happening for a long time is in
Switzerland they started prescribing
heroin to problematic heroin consumers
in 1994 and because of that they no
longer have a heroin problem they don't
have people dying from heroin they don't
in the Netherlands because the
Netherlands copied Switzerland and you
know the real kick in the teeth for us
in Britain is that the Swiss used
British evidence to do that to develop
that policy and since then
our organized crime have been getting
richer and richer from heroin and more
and more people have been dying whereas
in Switzerland they've halved their
burglaries they don't have people dying
from heroin and their organized crime
erupted that income stream and what
would you say to people who would say
something like you know if you make the
drugs freely available more people want
to try them and want to test them and
then potentially will get addicted to
them as a recreational thing well it
depends on the drug because we have to
treat each drug according to its
relative risks
The Most Dangerous Drug and this is
scientifically proven as well by the
comparators in report published in the
Lancet I think in 2007 various other
studies the most dangerous drug is
alcohol and we could control alcohol
better with better regulation but other
drugs need different regulation you know
cannabis
um it should be regulated with good
social Equity uh it needs to be
controlled so children can't get easy
access and the evidence is in from North
America that legally regulated markets
protect children better because child
consumption has gone down in those
markets and protecting our children is a
key and important part of what drug drug
policy should be now if you look at the
other drugs in the middle
MDMA for example there are huge numbers
of people using MDMA this weekend at
festivals like Boomtown
MDMA is the perfect example of a drug
which is not banned because it's
dangerous
it's dangerous because it's banned the
harm that's caused from mdmas from the
fact that it's an unregulated product
now
would more people take MDMA if it was
legally available for adults in a
licensed Pharmacy you know what I don't
know and I don't really care because
people don't get addicted to MDMA it's
not something that people develop a
problematic relationship with people who
consume it do so generally about three
or four times in 12 months three or four
times a year that's not something that
people develop a problem with so do I
care if even more people take MDMA and
dance to music in a field well it's done
oh whilst on that drug do I care no I
don't what I care about is are children
having easy access to it because
organized crime don't care who they sell
to what I care about is young people
dying or having Health difficulties from
an unregulated product that that's what
I care about
it's a really compelling argument and
logically makes complete sense I guess
as a final point to you you know to what
what do you want to happen what are you
campaigning for now and what would you
hope to see as a change in the next five
ten years
all right well as part of the law
enforcement Action Partnership we you
know we we campaign on a lot of things
now obviously
we want the full goal we want all of the
drugs legally regulated and controlled
but there are many reforms that we can
do and there's many things that we're
working on at the moment and I'm working
on
for incremental reforms so for example
in the UK at the moment we have record
drug deaths they do also in the states
they've got uh drug death problems
everywhere Australia or all around the
world
and most of those drug deaths are
opioids now there are simple ways while
we wait for our governments to prescribe
heroin to take control away from
organized crime while we wait there's
lots of things we can do we can have
overdose prevention centers which the UK
governments are dragging their feet with
and they're dragging their feet within
the U.S in Canada they have them
they save lives no one has died from an
overdose in an overdose prevention
center a place where people can go and
safely take their drugs
in the absence of Alvarez prevention
sites we can we can make ready access
and easy access to naloxone now naloxone
I always carry my kit because I'm
naloxone trained naloxone reverse is a
heroin overdose and if there was more
naloxone out there literally less people
would die oh half the people who die
from heroin die in company
and if someone which means that half at
least half of the deaths could be
prevented there is another issue I've
been working on and this is possibly the
most pressing issue that we could work
on
and that is the fact that we cannot
fight the climate crisis until we end
drug prohibition we can't
because for cop26 and for those that
don't know that was the climate crisis
of the climate conference at cop 26 the
wrong people around the table we needed
to have the drug cartels there right in
fact you could even say
only the drug cartels can save the
planet really because
all of the equatorial countries were
there and they signed up deforestation
pledges
but those pledges were meaningless
because they don't control their own
backyards Brazil signed the pledge
deforestation in Brazil has gone up 69
since
and the reason is that
those governments don't control those
forests
organize crime do right and it comes
back to the topic that we've been
talking about throughout this discussion
and that's corruption
and the fact that policing has caused
this corruption to be so big
that it's literally taken over entire
nations so West Africa for example
most of West Africa is a narco state
guinea guinea bissau Senegal
Guinea for example
apparently has the fastest deforestation
on Earth
and less than well about a year ago
there was a military coup there and that
military coup was about who controlled
the assets from the cocaine smuggling it
was basically a drug gang war
so these governments are now run by
transnational organized crime if you
look at the Mexican cartels for example
there used to be 20 cartels but policing
and the activities of the drug war means
that there's now only three right and
presumably they're much more powerful
and each one of those three now has much
more disposable income and they eat and
they have a bigger GDP those cartels
have a bigger GDP than West African
countries
and they've used that power to take over
those countries
so how can you get a government to agree
to a deforestation pledge when they're
not in control how can you do that well
you can't
and unfortunately
whereas deforestation is important
everywhere it's important that we Trump
plant trees in in
um in the UK or Sweden
or north of North America but it's not
as important that we maintain as we keep
the trees
in the green belt which is around the
the hottest part of the earth the
equator
because it's a quest is substantially
more carbon
and arguably it's the single most
important aspect of the fighting the
climate crisis because you can
eventually stop Nations burning coal but
you can't replant 500 year old trees in
the jungle and the Equator so
the only way we can solve this crisis is
through good governance
but the corruption
caused by
the War on Drugs
has taken away that governance
so we have to solve drug prohibition
first with
so we've got two simple choices we
either
seriously talk to the drug cartels or we
take their power away from them by
legally regulating the drug trades we
have no other choice
it's a fascinating conversation and it's
amazing to think that where we started a
little while ago was somebody going and
spending 20 quid by knocking on the door
and that sort of has sprawled into the
understanding about the implications for
ultimately what we're discussing now is
the entire human race isn't it well our
society at the very least look Neil it's
been an absolute pleasure to meet you
again and the thing that I always find
really fascinating about your story is
the fact that you were somebody who was
very good at a certain thing and were
open-minded enough to
completely reverse your mission in life
to almost the exact opposite of what
you'd been working at
um thank you so much for coming in thank
you for your time good luck thank you
good to see you as well good to see you
too and you look well by the way thank
you
foreign
[Music]
so that was Neil Woods an undercover
narcotics officer I'm joined now by the
episodes director Josh
um what were your thoughts on that very
depressing actually I found that
um yeah I'd agree just like someone that
has
you know a similar that he twists he
switched his entire view of what he's
doing and he dedicated his life to
something that he realized was making
the problem infinitely worse and we're
still there we're still fighting War on
Drugs and it just gets worse
takes a lot I guess to be able to admit
that to yourself that's something you've
dedicated your life to was was
making things worse the bit that really
stood up to me was when he said that
after seven or eight months of work and
96 people arrested they'd interrupted
the supply chain for two hours it's so
depressing isn't it I mean it just makes
you think what we are doing like yeah
and the way that you know that sort of
chain reaction of people funding drugs
for about drugs it's kind of like it's
just so systemic and
um it's clearly not going to work this
way but it feels like the political yeah
political social will is just not there
to to radically overhaul it and
effectively give out drugs regulate them
take it away from criminals put it on
governments but you just can't I can't
really see it properly happening
potentially decriminalization is
obviously the next step but as he's
saying like that that's not going to
solve the issue if where the drugs are
coming from they're they're being
controlled by you know criminal entities
what do you think brownie the standout
moment for me was at the end when he
talked about the impact of the drug
community and the criminality around
drugs and the environment that stuck in
my head so much and I'm going to be
thinking about that many days to come on
an angle I haven't heard before
and when he explained it it just made
complete sense and so much Clarity that
I couldn't believe I hadn't thought
about it before
and actually I found it quite impressive
um and admirable actually that it
sounded like it's come at a personal
cost for him oh yeah because he did
touch on the fact that he'd been
diagnosed with complex PTSD and he
mentioned some things quite casually
that sound really traumatic
but he still carries on
on his mission he's you know he's got a
steadfast about it exactly and I think
that's really admirable
everyone always asked me to do this one
on stream
[Music]
um
[Music]